연산이에요. 안타깝게도 3비트 반복 코드는 위상 플립을 감지하는 데 완전히 실패해요. 예를 들어, 우리가
이전처럼 3비트 반복 코드로 qubit를 인코딩하고 중간 qubit에 위상 플립 오류가 발생한다고 가정하면
화면에 표시된 상태를 얻게 돼요. 이건 인코딩하기 전에 원래 qubit에 위상 플립이 발생했을 때 얻었을 인코딩과 정확히 같아요.
그래서 같은 방식으로
이전과 같은 circuit를 수행해서 오류를 감지하려 하면 신드롬 00을 얻게 돼요. 이는 오류가 없었다고 잘못 제안하는 거예요.
그래서 3비트 반복 코드는 최대 하나의 비트 플립 오류에는 작동하지만 위상 플립 오류를 감지하는 데는 실패해요.
사실 어떤 의미에서는 상황을 더 나쁘게 만드는데, 위상 플립을 경험할 수 있는 qubit이 세 배나 더 많아지니까요.
3비트 반복 코드가 위상 플립 오류를 완전히 무시한다는 걸 알았어요. 그러니 이런 종류의 오류를 다루는 데는 별로 도움이 안 되는 것 같아요.
하지만 사실 3비트 반복 코드를 수정해서 위상 플립 오류도 감지하도록 만들 수 있어요. 이게 어떻게 되는지 지금 설명할게요.
3비트 반복 코드를 사용해 qubit를 인코딩하는 원래 circuit가 있고, 우리가 수정하는 방법은 매우 간단해요. 그냥
인코딩의 각 qubit에 Hadamard gate를 적용하면 돼요. Hadamard gate는 0 상태를 플러스 상태로 변환하고 1
상태를 마이너스 상태로 변환해요. 그래서 순 효과는 화면에 표시된 상태를 얻는 거예요. 여기서
플러스 플러스 플러스와 마이너스 마이너스 마이너스는 세 플러스 상태 또는 세 마이너스의 텐서에 대한 약식 표기예요.
상태죠. 위상 플립 오류, 즉 Z gate는 플러스 상태를 마이너스 상태로, 마이너스 상태를
플러스 상태로 변환해요. 그래서 이 인코딩은 위상 플립 오류를 감지하고 정정하는 데 유용할 거예요. 그러기 위해 이전의
오류 감지 circuit를 다음과 같이 수정할 수 있어요.
이전 circuit에서 화면에 표시된 것처럼 시작과 끝에 Hadamard gate를 추가할 거예요.
아이디어는 매우 간단해요. 처음 세 Hadamard gate가 플러스와 마이너스 상태를 다시 0과 1 상태로 변환해요.
같은 패리티 검사가 이전처럼 수행되고, 두 번째 Hadamard gate 레이어가 우리를
인코딩으로 되돌려요. 이를 생각하는 다른 방법은 기본적으로 Hadamard 연산으로 켤레를 취함으로써 위상 플립 오류를 비트 플립 오류로 변환하는 거예요.
그런데 circuit를 조금 단순화할 수 있어요. 이 circuit는 완전히 동일해요.
원하신다면 직접 확인해 보세요. 인코딩된 qubit를 이 circuit에 넣으면
위상 플립 오류가 발생하지 않았다고 가정하면 신드롬 00을 얻어요. 위상 플립이 없었음을 나타내는 거죠.
오류가 없다는 걸 나타내요. 상단 qubit에 위상 플립 오류가 있다면, 가장 오른쪽 플러스와 마이너스가 뒤집혀요.
그러면 다른 오류 신드롬 01이 나와요. 이 경우 비트 플립에서 했던 것처럼 위상 플립의 위치를 식별해요.
그러면 상단 qubit에 Z gate를 적용해서 정정할 수 있어요. 상황은
다른 두 qubit 중 하나에서 위상 플립 오류가 발생한 경우에도 비슷해요. 사실 이 코드를 사용해서 최대 하나의 위상 플립 오류를 감지하고
정정할 수 있어요. 하지만 안타깝게도 이미 짐작하셨을 수 있지만, 이제 더 이상
비트 플립 오류를 정정할 수 없어요. 하지만 아직 희망은 있어요. 사실 이 두 코드를
결합해서 비트 플립과 위상 플립 오류 모두 정정할 수 있는 코드를 얻을 수 있거든요. 실제로
단일 qubit의 임의적인 오류를 정정할 수 있게 될 거예요. 이제 9 qubit Shore 코드에 대해 논의할 시간이에요. 이건 Quantum
오류 정정 코드로, 우리가 방금 본 두 코드, 즉 3비트를 결합해서 얻을 수 있어요.
단일 비트 플립 오류를 정정할 수 있는 반복 코드와 단일 위상 플립을 정정할 수 있는 수정된 버전을 결합하는 거예요.
오류를 결합하는 거예요. 더 정확하게 말하면, 9 qubit Shore 코드는 두 코드를 연결해서 얻는 코드예요. 이는
먼저 하나의 qubit를 세 개로 인코딩하는 하나의 인코딩을 적용하고, 그다음 각
세 qubit에 개별적으로 다른 인코딩을 적용하는 걸 의미해요. 그래서 총 9개의 qubit를 얻게 돼요. 이를
circuit 다이어그램 형태로 다음과 같이 표현할 수 있어요. 먼저 위상 플립 오류를 감지하는 3비트 반복 코드의 수정된 버전을 적용하고
오류를 감지할 거예요. 그런 다음 원래의
3비트 반복 코드를 사용해 결과 qubit를 독립적으로 각각 인코딩해요. circuit를 조금 줄이면
좀 더 공간을 만들 수 있는데, 원래 qubit에 대한 두 표준 기저 상태가 어떻게
인코딩되는지를 설명함으로써 코드를 약간 다른 방식으로 지정할 수 있어요.
이걸 알면 선형성에 의해 임의적인 qubit 상태 벡터가 어떻게
인코딩되는지 결정할 수 있어요. 그게 바로 9 qubit Shore 코드예요. 한 코드가 위상 플립을 정정하고
다른 코드가 비트 플립 오류를 정정해요. 앞으로 보게 되겠지만 이는 실제로 단일 qubit의 임의적인 오류를 정정할 수 있음을 의미해요.
이제 9 qubit Shore 코드를 사용해서 오류를 감지하고 정정하는 방법을 알아봐요. 비트 플립 오류, X 오류라고도 하는 것부터 시작할게요.
인코딩을 수행하는 circuit가 있고, 얘기하기 쉽게 이 코드에서 얻는 9개의 qubit를
세 개의 qubit로 이루어진 세 블록으로 그룹화해서 생각할 거예요. 각 블록은
두 번째 인코딩 단계를 적용해서 얻는 인코딩을 나타내요.
두 번째 인코딩 단계는 이 맥락에서 내부 코드라고 불리는 일반 3비트 반복 코드예요.
반면 외부 코드는 첫 번째 인코딩 단계에 사용되는 코드로, 이 경우 위상 플립 오류에 작동하는
3비트 반복 코드의 수정된 버전이에요. 비트 플립 오류를 정정하려면 각 블록을
개별적으로 처리하면 돼요. 각 블록은 3비트 반복 코드를 사용한 qubit의 인코딩이고
그 코드는 비트 플립 오류로부터 보호해요. 먼저 qubit 중 하나에 X 오류가 발생한다고 가정해 봐요.
예를 들어 중간 블록의 중간 qubit처럼요. 각 블록을 독립적으로 비트 플립 오류가 있는지 검사하고
발견된 오류를 정정하면, 이 오류는 정정되고 원래 인코딩이
복구될 거예요. 사실 여러 X 오류가 있어도 오류가
별도의 블록에 있는 한 이런 방식으로 정정할 수 있어요. 단일 블록에 두 개 또는 세 개의 X 오류가 있으면 문제가 되지만
블록당 최대 하나의 X 오류만 있다면 내부 코드가 이를 잡아내고 원래 인코딩된 상태를 복구할 수 있어요.
그래서 이 코드에서 비트 플립 오류를 정정하는 건 꽤 간단한 문제예요. 위상 플립 오류도 고려해야 해요.
즉 Z 오류예요. 이번에는 무엇을 해야 할지가 그렇게 명확하지 않아요. 외부 코드가 위상 플립 오류를 정정하는 것이지만
내부 코드가 어떻게든 방해하기 때문에 직접적으로 감지하고 정정할 수 없어요.